I had two friends that were like all you
having a boy like I'll teach them how to
teach my to throw a ball like I do it I
can I can throw a ball like what are you
talking you start with that guy my path
is like a genderqueer person my
understanding about gender is that
ultimately it doesn't mean anything it
doesn't give you the information about
that person that you think that it's
gonna give you the person I am today was
like very much in line with a person
that I was or longed to be when I was
really little I was a tomboy my best
friends were primarily boys I played
with boy stuff that changed as I became
a teenager and wanted to fit in more and
just wasn't comfortable being myself I
was still kind of figure out who I was
and you know that took a long time from
that time until my early 30s my
queerness in terms of my gender sort of
continued to transform
I was it's a very beginning of deciding
to try to have a baby by myself so I'm
always known that I wanted to have kids
someday I thought I probably would end
up trying to go down the path of having
a baby alone also I just didn't know the
right person was out there to take that
journey with when we got ready to go on
our first date my best friends at the
time they asked me to not talk about
wanting to have kids with Michelle I'd
brought it up I think on some other
casual dates a little too soon because
it was something that was really it was
important to me but with Michelle they
said I should boy slow my roll a little
bit and not knowing that she was
actually trying to have a baby people
will ask you you have a boy or girl for
whatever that means that this person
could be anybody you hear that right
away you're hearing like boys are like
this and girls are like that but as soon
as we found out that we are having a boy
something just sort of clicked we have
this amazing person and whoever that
person is they're perfect but you also
you like all of these like
stereotypically boy things I would say
things like Oh God like what if he wants
to play sports and you'd be like that's
great I'll be the coach it's really
funny because he's super into sports
like maybe he was like an Olympic
athlete in his past life he just came
with all of these sporting talents that
hurt like visible at 17 months
that's what daschle like growing up she
just like easily relates to him on that
level I'm constantly trying to like
queer my relationship with him and get
him to wear tutus he hates it like he's
just like now when I catch myself trying
to do these things it ends up really
just making me feel really retro and
dumb about gender it just takes me away
from the reality of like him like
Atticus like who is he what what does he
want and the sort of purity of the
things that he's interested in are
delighted by obviously I want to support
whatever heat he wants to be this group
is the Rolie polies group it's like this
really big mons group I shouldn't have
like moment
hearing mom's grew other dads their
other other people like me I'm
definitely aware of being his Baba
Daschle goes by Baba and that's
something that a lot more masculine
female people and even some trans men
who her parents are going by baba as an
alternative to mano de hide but they've
all been awesome I really like the moms
that are in our group very much I
haven't felt weird for not being a
traditional mom it's really nice to have
that support group for sure he is taking
in kind of kid media and he has this
great book that's like just pictures and
words but when you open it up it's like
a picture of a girl in a picture of a
boy and it's like girl boy I'm just like
child child this is where he starts
learning like what things are and so I
hate the idea that he's getting
imprinted on him people who look like
this are boys and people who look like
that or girls even something that's like
progressive like Sesame Street all the
monsters are boys unless they have like
a bow in their hair and the sparkly
necklace on like why is Old MacDonald
like a guy why couldn't it be a lesbian
farmer it's everywhere I mean it is it's
everywhere I think those are things that
we are probably more aware of the most
people anyway but with him are probably
really sensitive to it sometimes the
best thing to do
feels like to be constantly challenging
and then sometimes it's almost just to
ignore gender completely and he's being
raised by a gender non-conforming person
so just the existence of daschle is
going to be a huge piece of information
about the reality of what gender is or
isn't it's easy to take for granted
sometimes the environments that were in
because they are special but they're
still small all of these questions and
concerns that we have about gender I
know tons of straight couples we have
these exact same questions and concerns
everybody needs to be reconsidering the
way that they're presenting gender to
their kids it's not even whether or not
Atticus is personally going to be a
gender queer gender fluid person
Atticus could grow up and be a
completely traditionally cisgendered
male and he needs to understand the
variety of genders that are out there so
he can be respectful of human being in
the world
hi-yah